it was a situation in which no matter
what I did it you didn't quite get the
validation that you were seeking so
you're always chasing it a little bit
more a little bit more
um to the point where unbeknownst to me
or on an unconscious level like I needed
to escape that Paradigm and my first
Escape was was through drugs and alcohol
and every time I had done something or
said something that I regretted
it was when I was drinking and I thought
at one point maybe I don't want to live
a life where I'm continually wishing
that I hadn't said or done something and
I just spiraled out control I didn't
care I didn't want to live I'd lost the
passion to live